[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening look at this full theater
how many people here along now members
thank you all as you can see we've been
showing parts of or the hole keeper of
the clock the story by Danny Hillis
which some of you may have been seeing
pieces of in your email or all of you
hopefully a couple reminders tonight
after the show we'd love to have all of
you members we're gonna cram up here on
the stage and no one's gonna fall into
the organ Bay and we're gonna take an
awesome member photo so we don't want to
miss that opportunity and as you have
seen from the story of keeper of the
clock in the campaign that we've been
running we've been trying to do it in a
different way and we think that this
year of all years it's an interesting
year to be paying attention to the
cultural institutions that we care the
most about and I know we all care about
different ones in different ways and we
have appreciated all of your support
over the years and thank you very much
for that this particular year we also
worked hard to get the the wearable
version of the Rosetta disk at a at a
rate that was less than 25 thousand
dollars and so that's a that's a gift
for people who are able to give $1,000
or more this year and a bunch of you
have already taken advantage of those
early numbered sets so thank you so much
for that we really appreciate it it's
really helping us a lot and Stewart is
going to introduce Rick now is the time
if you have an electronic device to
leave it on
use it if you want so these are home
movies by and large and you know home is
a beloved house usually well when you
aggregate them you get the home movies
of a beloved city even a beloved region
and the great aggregator is the bloated
Rick Prelinger
[Applause]
Thank You Stewart in sander as always
it's a unreal and wonderful pleasure to
be here thank you all for coming this
year it's great to see you're here for
the 11th time unbelievably this is
unfortunately not an ordinary night and
it's not an ordinary month for that
matter what landscapes takes place
through the kindness and generosity of
long now foundation it's part of their
series of talks about long-term thinking
and one very long-term institution is
the Commons resources and land that no
one owns held canonically for common
uses in england the physical Commons
were enclosed in the 17th and 18th
centuries and a land was returned to
private landowners but that was not the
end in a fascinating book that I've just
begun to read on misbehaving
Elizabeth Maddock Dylan describes how
the popular sense of the Commons made
its way from the land into the theatre
18th century audience members didn't go
to the theatre just to see a play
they went to represent themselves to
make common space and often common cause
in 1804
a Boston journalist complained bitterly
that the theater didn't have bright
enough lighting during the show because
people weren't just there for the
performance and when Richard the third
was performed at the Bowery Theatre in
New York in 1832 over 300 audience
members swarmed the stage so that they
could help they could assist in slaying
the tyrannical King
this wouldn't happen in the quiet and
dark theaters of today but though it may
be dark in the Castro tonight it won't
be quiet
this shows part of a long tradition of
making the Commons and if we attend to
the Commons and protect it it can help
us survive through bright times and dark
times
like many of us in this room our friends
and fellow artists at Oakland tried to
make a Commons of their own we're now
learning how greed and how an inflexible
property market turned a bit of utopia
and to a scene of tragedy I hope you'll
find ways to support survivors and the
families of those who are lost and
contribute to the funds that have been
set up but more than that I hope you'll
find ways to support the commons as best
you can
this means many things defending the
right of DIY spaces and venues to exist
helping them become safer and supporting
the struggles of all people whose rights
to the city are under attack there's a
host of ways to do this just look around
you and see who needs help so thanks as
always too long now for making this
amazing event possible we're two nights
this week tomorrow night it is a night
specially devoted to pray linger library
and Megan and I and the prelude girl
library community thank all of you
who've so kindly supported our library
through the purchase of patron tickets
and many other acts of support this
means more to us and to the people who
use the library then you will ever know
and we'll talk about that more tomorrow
but now as I always say before each show
you are the soundtrack every show is
different please identify people places
and events ask questions engage in
friendly disputes with your neighbors
and enjoy the next 72 minutes thanks so
much
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
the fog here has a beauty all its own as
it drifts and billows in from the sea
thick and silent here the fog is seldom
sinister or depressing as you may know
it elsewhere here the natives boast they
have a special kind of fog that befits a
special kind of city a city with a
fabled landmark that is known the world
over the Golden Gate the Golden Gate of
San Francisco just a little more than a
century ago this metropolis on the
Pacific Ocean was a little Spanish
village called yerba buena before it was
renamed by the American
hey this city is often called the
capital of the West 1939
[Music]
[Music]
it's magic our on the ferry
1939-1940 Golden Gate International
Exposition beautiful orange boat
SFO
19:39 again coming in from the south
[Music]
sixty-four I believe
weird about seventh I think we're
standing about seven
if she only knew
during the early 60s of course
[Music]
and so this sequence was shot in 64
during the time of the Republican
National Convention in San Francisco
when
a far-right candidate Barry Goldwater
was up for nomination and people were
proposing William Scranton of
Pennsylvania Margaret chase Smith of
Maine and others as alternatives
Goldwater got the nomination of course I
think this was the Scranton crowd that
shot this movie
right rent-a-car five a day five cents a
mile
so the comfortable north of market
these are longshoremen footage that was
newly restored by Library of Congress we
haven't attributed this to a specific
date yet they're either showing their
strength or they're marching one one
during the 34 or 36 longshore strikes
working man you still wear their jackets
to work
that's the Old Market Darrow YMCA I
think isn't it
before the freeway
suspicious one
[Music]
and this is Labor Day either 35 or 36
these are the longshoremen just one
union recognition that he showed up on
Market Street as a show of strength you
can mess with us
[Applause]
and it's January 8 1939 a new footage
that was just discovered by Knicks Park
in LA people are gathering at the Ferry
Building you can see the Union banners
in the background and they're here to
celebrate something that happened the
day before On January 7 and that was the
release of Tom Mooney from San Quentin
Tom Mooney had been it's widely thought
that he had been framed in the 1916
bombing of preparedness day was a labor
hero during the Russian Revolution
Russians yelled Mooney Mooney in front
of the American consulate the worldwide
in a lot of ways he might have been the
Mumia abu-jamal of his time are they and
here he is very very sick he died a
couple years after but this was a major
major event the prison food did not
agree with him
yes the old public library
I think the armbands are union members
who are acting as security typical
auditorium
our mandatory
glasha
and the Communist Party newspaper that's
his next shot in his own movie welcoming
Mooney and then the parade's aren't over
victory parade 1945 I've cut it way down
but it's interesting as you will see
plenty good bands I don't have any bad
ones and here are some Chinese American
community organizations
remember Uncle Joe was still our ally
See's Candies just two doors down from
painless Parker the dentist
[Music]
the informal celebration afterwards not
as out of control as VJ day thank God
and this is 1975 what was then called
the gave freedom parade now pride June
29
[Applause]
[Music]
there been a few edits to make this
family-friendly I'm sorry
I know censorship every City Hall
afterwards
this some of you may have seen this as
upper mark this is um what they call mid
market we've just crossed Van Ness and
we're heading in and we're going to go
past a site of rapid real-estate
development right now yeah this is the
late 40s
well there's a lot of street life and a
lot of small businesses instead of those
big empty there's the Twitter building
Merchandise Mart
[Music]
dancing and there's a vegetable market
there at the corner of a Community
Market at the corner of 8th and so we've
missed it blocked while the cameraman
changed film and we're on that block
between 6th and 7th
so many theaters you could spend your
day in the movies painless Parker again
and we turn on to six
and you know I don't know very much
about this this it's an outtake from the
official San Francisco Convention and
Visitor's Bureau film in the late 50s
and early 60s but I just liked seeing
people walk in the rain
I think it's Chinese New Year's
this is you know between 57 and 62 so
this is around will see a date in a
minute I think it's 58 and I've cheated
a little bit this is the richmond-san
Rafael ferry but it is so beautiful it
was shot by a real artist and it really
gives a flavor of that mode of travel
that's the ferry went between well
where's the ferry slip oh there's people
ask the question aloud we have a
question about where the ferry departed
and coin Richmond
the bridge is new when these boats were
sailing the Russian River
[Music]
1944
1938
yeah the shell building
festive market notice fosters on the
right
you know I'm I haven't figured that out
Joseph market third and Kearney Lauda's
fountain
so if I had to guess this is
you know I'm wondering about the flags
off to think about that
where's everybody I mean the streets are
a little empty
that's that building that was for many
years the Redevelopment Agency and I was
worn down that Deco building
yes
and then this is a family's tourist
films from 1956 Chinatown and around
downtown
just um if you're shooting home video
for the record please go easy on the
statues and shoot like this
yeah we're looking down from quit power
working waterfront
but I think this is Sunday morning or
something it's just very quiet
[Music]
[Music]
it's really not as good on your phone is
it
throughout the mats in the line through
Hawaii
19:56 it's still an active prison of
course sometimes in home movies you can
see inmates in the yards not so much
this one
[Music]
56 or when did it close you have 62 the
old Hall of Justice
Portsmouth square
little visit to Coit Tower when it was
really no more than two or three years
old that guy kind of looks like
hurricane that it can't be
and the usual from probably the st.
Francis sometimes the top of the mark
this I think is the st. Francis because
we're in the elevator
the Embarcadero freeways up most of the
way Columbus Avenue you can still see
the Montgomery block down at the tip
they're just starting custom house just
starting to see new buildings and you
know our Manhattan style downtown is
just starting up
so mission Street
I think third to fourth this is a film
from a National Cash Register salesman
and look what it ends up showing Mission
Street this is their their old
headquarters soon to be replaced
mission between third and fourth soon to
be replaced by this beautiful new
building built in 1960 and torn down
soon after that if Gary and gob now not
all of you are familiar with a gariand
Golf & Cathedral Hill area but for those
of you who are this is a real glimpse of
an alternate universe because none of
this is here anymore you know where Gary
splits into those Peter yorck and Star
King and the Cathedral Hill just up the
street a little bit
doesn't have that little rotating thing
on it if it anything if it does well
you'll see a two-way Gary as well so the
NCR building has finished around 1960 if
I can trust Google
I think that's st. Mark's down there I'm
not mistaken but then from the building
this is there's no Cathedral and there
is no Cathedral Hill apartments it's
just not built yet that's a I think a
private is that a Catholic girls school
st. Vincent's thank you one new building
is up
that's at California
and in the Mission Bay area I believe
this is a 1937-38
and when you didn't have heavy tow
trucks to come and clean up after an
accident you had to kind of do it by
hand
self-reliance
[Applause]
and this man took a moment from
photographing crashes and accidents to
catch the army airforce in the sky and
then he shot another one and this is in
the Embarcadero and that beautiful car
has a hit a beautiful Market Street
Railway bus or vice versa
and spectators are riveted to the scene
and then everything starts moving again
and hold on to your seats newbies
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
outtake from the 1957 film the lineup
and man who photographed car crashes
also did urban panoramas which are kind
of nice I like this one our modest
skyline in the 30s
yeah I think it's the South he's part of
the city but but look at this this is
the this is Hunter's Point prewar
and here's the dry docks but it's quite
hunter five before the land was taken
and they built the where worker housing
it's really a bit of a still a bit of a
fishing village
right they were shrimp shrimp Fisher's
there that's the Bay Bridge and this is
some footage that we have by the
kindness of the Market Street Railway
who runs our fabulous historic
streetcars who shared some footage with
us and the Western neighborhoods project
so a few of you may have seen this
before I just picked out a look yeah
let's hear it for the western
neighborhoods project tireless local
historians who um that's a work
all right can we narrate can somebody
explain this
this is the Sacramento clay cable
anybody want to talk about what's
special about this line
so cable cars going right to the Ferry
Building
and this is Castro Street
it's the Castro Street car
relying on child labor to keep the fares
cheap so this is the counterbalance card
if somebody want to explain how that
works right so the weight of one car
going down pulls the other car up like a
funicular and incline yes
I'm they during World War Two as n't it
and I just this is a apparently a
railfan trip sometime in the 40s and I
included this because you're out in the
sunset in the Richmond and it's just so
unfinished you see the sand dune with a
billboard on top of it I'm a sucker for
home movies that show sand dunes in and
the outer the outer neighborhoods where
was this
so this is Judah
yeah but I think the signs are not
another dude looks like it's for sale
and those of you who commute up 19th
Avenue as I did are familiar with this
process north of stones town
and here's the rail fans waving decades
they call them foam words
this subject before in the classroom I
just like to briefly go over the purpose
of the direction level once again this
control which probably remind you of a
gear shift in an automobile has nothing
to do with the changing of gears but
does change the direction of the coach
and therefore is called a directional
lever to go forward the control is
placed in the forward running position
by pushing xi straight to the front to
go forward the control is placed in the
forward running position by pushing the
lever straight to the front enable a
coach to move backward the lever is
shifted to the rear position neutral
position is right in between or straight
up fortunately for the operator the foot
power pedal used in all our electric
trolley coaches has eliminated this
troublesome annoyance this device
automatically passes the amount of
current that can be taken by the motor
and measures it out accordingly when the
part that was depressed it operates an
automatic can't control in the switch
group which opens and closes relay
switches to distribute the electric
power of the 144 horsepower engine thus
the acceleration provided is even and
smooth
this is the produce market which is now
an area of Washington and Davis streets
now it's the golden gateway development
and this is a 30s piece of footage an
outtake from some film some sort of a
chase is taking place there we have this
is the only lengthy exterior footage
I've ever found in the produce market
it's interesting because we see all this
kind of lightly used land right in the
city center but this year for the first
time I made a rather surprising
discovery which was the first footage
shot inside the old produce market and
so we're going to look at a little bit
of a film which is called as the city
sleeps a semi dramatized film about a
worker in the San Francisco produce
market and his day
by the time Al and I get back from
coffee Charlie's got plenty of work
lined up for us the markets really
getting busy right at this one house
several trucks are waiting to be
unloaded
[Music]
all over the market in wholesale houses
like this one truck after truck comes
rolling in strawberries tomatoes
asparagus grapefruit carrots melons
crate after crate all night long
[Music]
[Music]
as fast as the lumpers can get the food
unloaded each shipment has to be sorted
out by the porter
[Music]
it has to be weighed and graded so the
right price can be put on it the floor
men are experts at figuring the price of
a shipment just by looking at a few
samples it takes an expert to set a
price high enough to make a profit and
still low enough to meet the competition
so the food will sell fast
[Music]
[Music]
it's daylight by the time the last truck
is unloaded and a lumper knows by then
he's done a good night's work 60,000
pounds a night five nights a week
that's my average and I don't mind
saying I'm proud of it
now the market is jam-packed with fresh
fruits and vegetables and even before
the day has really begun the retail
dealers are in to take it to the
neighborhood markets and store
about the time I'm finished with my job
the rest of the people in San Francisco
are just starting on the way to their
jobs
first in those times on the way home I
feel like I've been feeding the whole
city single-handed I like to walk
through the morning crowds they don't
know me but I feel like I've been doing
something important for them and I guess
some of the other guys feel the same way
hey Albert walking home from work is
alright but after a night in the market
I could use a lift home I'm kind of glad
Charlie came along he goes out my way
right where is this Charlie's a trout
fisherman - I remember once in the days
we used to take the streetcar together
we got talking trout fishing so hard I
forgot to get off at my stop the guys
who work right in the wholesale market
get to like fresh fruit and vegetables
charlie had some of the first melons of
the season picked out nice of him to
give me one nothing tastes better for
breakfast and a good melon Charlie's a
good guy always doing something like
that
[Music]
yes sir there's nothing like getting
home from a good night's work coming up
your own Street looking forward to a
good hot meal and a hot bath a chance to
relax and talk to the wife and
especially no more stuff to live but I
say no more stuff to live yes sir 60,000
pounds a night
[Music]
all right heads up anybody recognize
this seal stadium this is now the mall
you know at 16th and Potrero
it's a rodeo going on I left these ins
you can see the signs Pinocchio's
the International Settlement
Eskimo Pie
so this is around I don't understand the
war bonds because this is before this is
pre-war from as best I can tell
late 30s
and one of my faves the crowd leaving
candlestick sometime in the early 60s a
little bit of orange but but the
merchandising was a lot less intensive
and the crowds were a lot less diverse
it's a bit sober isn't it
this is thoroughly about 62 ish it's a
little hard to tell exactly
as the Ritz cracker is that's what I
want
a little bit of mysterious footage from
the 30s anybody know where this is
and my part of town the Richmond
District
I love richmond district home movies you
know there lot of them
sometime in the 30s and this is footage
from the DN family which came to us
through Nicole Lavelle shot around
1955-56 and there you know from an
artistic point of view I described their
sensibility as kind of dreamy realism
that's aunt Helene
[Music]
[Laughter]
and this is some stones town when it's
relatively new
dressed up for a trip to the Jonestown
Fort Point when it was still a ruin
notice the lack of international
visitors pre container days
the headlands
a submarine
and this is um old Bayshore Highway now
the traffic congestion has moved over to
the 101 of course and in the background
we see well let's not get ahead of
ourselves here's the Cow Palace in
Geneva Avenue back when it was called
the livestock pavilion you can do it
so this dog this chained monkey has a
human toy which he's taking apart it's
only fair so we're in Brisbane and I've
cheated a little bit because it's so
beautiful we have a Brisbane resident
who might be able to tell us where this
is it's 1937-38 this was a longshoreman
the Communist longshoreman who shot Tom
Mooney also shot this and it's the good
life in the hills
still in the for15
Easter
[Music]
it's like a jug of wine
well he's a longshoreman you know it's
physical labor he's lifting 60,000
pounds a day
and the Bayshore Highway we many of us
still drive so it is August 1928 and
this is footage that comes to us from
Mary Coe because it's her grandfather
this was transferred and comes to us
from the excellent move that film
transfer great place to get your film
transferred San Francisco they're
artists and this man if I can get some
light his name brawlin kroff who's a
dentist downtown and a member of the
dolphins and he's swimming the golden
gate along with some other people before
the bridge and this was an annual
competitive swim it appears that dr.
Croft aim in third or any of his
relatives here tonight no I think
tomorrow we'll see somebody but quite an
impressive specimen
[Music]
he swam in the bay and said every day
before work
right
I think the shark repellent is all those
oars and he shows up somewhere near well
for point or Chrissy
[Music]
[Applause]
and now it's time to celebrate
right there's the Coast Guard building
right now it's the Maryland's Marine
Sanctuary office the rumble seat
and California Street in the Richmond
near where Cornwall that irregular
Street pattern or to Street patterns
meet
you must remember of course the streets
and sidewalks were swept more than once
a day in those days so it was the
difference
19:44 some Scenic's of the san francisco
almost completely without automobiles
during the war when gas was rationed a
lot of people put with their cars up on
blocks yes
Lyons Street
Conservatory Red Cross
yeah I mean I think it's it's yeah
portals of the past that could have been
the first shot of course now 1973 beta
breakers this was a smaller race that
year and this was shot by this is the
beginning the front of the race right
not a lot of fanfare no helicopters
and this comes from the Laval family who
shot this and we don't know who that guy
is from Oregon but we know this guy
coming up in the let's see where are we
in the red shorts and the st. Ignatius
shirt is Dan Laval is in the audience
tonight did you think this would be
shown at the Castro
so Playland has just been torn down and
they're building the apartments so
here's a very rare view of the immediate
post Playland environment after the
ruins have been cleared away
seventy-three
[Applause]
running home alright Nicole who's this
how much did you make a dollar around
and this is um what is this 76 the snow
in much stick I guess and this is also a
Louisville family movie around the same
year where Chrissy field when it was
still a Superfund site
if you prefer the beach the Pacific
Ocean provides you with a playground
which stretches its invitation for miles
one of the most intriguing sites around
San Francisco is Sutro Baths just a few
hundred yards offshore
which is the stage for a strange
phenomenon of nature like the swallows
of Capistrano much further south the
seals return to Seal Rock on the same
day they're not sales and delight
tourists with their end
[Music]
these are home movies of a very very
long trip through the West undertaken by
two african-american women in the late
50s anybody want to explain the pipeline
[Music]
brief shot when it was Whitney's
Nawal which is now our ruin
and you know i'm a proud resident of the
richmond district so we're gonna take a
little bit of a speed tour
another outtake from the lineup
the hotel's not there and the gas
station is no seal Rock end
this is Clemente well
you have Fort Miley on the right
one of the lovely things about this
neighborhood is it hasn't changed that
much at least visually they're they're
called speed humps there's a difference
[Music]
and to Lincoln Park
yes
have a date with Carlotta Valdes
[Laughter]
and it's April 15 1967 a few shots of
what people look like it one of the
first big marches against the Vietnam
War
[Applause]
hipster couple of the time
wild and crazy guys
[Applause]
and I don't know what your this is but
the Lavelle family is going for a ride
on the fire both Phoenix but first let's
look at the waterfront and the beautiful
freeway this has got to be 71 to 72 as
my guess Bank of America building is up
but something else isn't finished as you
will soon see
you spill the coffee for the right
so this looks like it's a it's like a
regular patrol around the northern
waterfront that's pretty cool here 15
and 17 which is now the beautiful
Exploratorium but we still have a kind
of modest skyline compared to what we've
got now
San Franciscans boast that their city as
a moderate year-round temperature and
the healthiest climate in the world
the fog banks which roll in from the
Pacific are San Franciscan st. merely
invigorating seen mists bringing health
wealth and happiness to the wonder city
of the West
[Music]
thank you thank you thank you all
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you